je sais c'est l'une des plus brillantes
vénitienne française donc elle est
comment non j'ai dit d'une j'ai pas dis
là et je dis lui n'y est plus elle s'est
fait taper dessus parce que courir ciel
vie lorsqu'il ça c'est un art qui quand
même dû lancer elle raconte n'importe
quoi
non c'est donner des faits au lieu de
réagir débattu avec madame
malheureusement j'en garde un très
douloureux souvenir si vous êtes
douloureux si vous mettez un pansement
morts j'ai commencé quand les hostilités
à ce poids là on disait que vous allez
juger ce soir là vous aviez dit que
prendre enfin se soumettre à la
situation
c'était comme une autoroute après je
vais vous dire alors des permis sont là
par les aventures il ya une chose et son
palace on l'aurait j'ai dérangé
peut-être que je vous ai déranger ce
soir l'europe et sur les soupers laisser
parler j'ai arrêter avec vos histoires
la vérité elle est tout autre chez que
effectivement d'habitude je m'exprime en
public uniquement sur les questions de
bioéthique
c'est la seule chose c'est que je me
suis sera jamais exprimé en public au
grand public
parce qu'effectivement c'est une
dimension qui m'importe c'est la
dimension de la vie
là j'ai dû m'exprimer pourquoi parce
qu'en fait il y avait tout et n'importe
quoi qui sortait en permanence alors je
vais vous raconter une histoire c'est
l'histoire d'un virus dont tout le monde
et il était absolument certain que ce
virus ils venaient du pangolin ou la
chauve-souris c'était même un consensus
scientifique et que toute personne qui
s'opposaient à cette doxa était notre
jeu pour prendre ce recul des bois je
suis d'accord avec vous quand même
est-ce que aujourd'hui alexandra chacun
ya un moment où l on m'a dit j'ai une
question à vous poser avec des gars là
est la raison tant sur ses tourments
disais que ça faisait d'un pont gaulin
d'une chauve-souris aujourd'hui on ne
sait plus d'où vient ce vaccin par
éthique qui viendrait d'un laboratoire
en chine il vient d'où alors tu eu lieu
en tout cas la version officielle russe
officielle aujourd'hui c'est 2-2 l'om
est 7e
ça serait que de fao çi c'est vrai que
ce serait plutôt une fuite de
laboratoires de lujan ça c'est pas moi
qui le dis moi la seule chose que je
regarde
c'était la séquence mais je disais mais
une séquence comme ça a construite de
cette façon là c'est compliqué
d'imaginer qu'elle vienne d'un pogo l'un
ou d'une chauve-souris
voilà alors ça c'est une première chose
après la deuxième chose j'ai alerté sur
la l'usagé du masque à contretemps
effectivement qu est ce qu on a vu
quelques temps après on a eu des
contrats d'aidé des contradictions à
longueur de temps etc
l'autre truc sur lequel j'ai été donc
sur le l'origine du visa à l'acteur en
avril 2020 would you do you j'ai alors
j'ai toujours dit que je ne voyais pas
comment nous aurions jamais la moindre
certitude sur le sujet parce que en fait
compte tenu de l'analyse génétique de la
bestiole il ya tout lieu de penser que
ça résulte d'une logique humaine qu'on
appelle de gains de fonction et qu'on
est donc qui donne une espèce de
fonction qui est pile entre deux
protéines à st eve 2 bref toujours est
il que dès lors qu'il ya ça c'est une
sorte de signature d'un d'ingénierie
humaine d'accord ça veut pas dire c'est
une certitude
ça veut dire que la question se pose et
c'est pour cela que je vais au brésil
angola vous n'y croyez pas du tout je
fus genevois non je ne peux pas y croire
effectivement j'ai vraiment du mal
après je conçois que la la la question
continue à se poser
d'accord et que contrairement à mes
petits copains qui actuellement est un
consensus scientifique a encore était
pas sorti en disant cette fois on est
sûr qu'il est d'origine de laboratoire
pour moi la seule certitude c'est un
cahier de laboratoire et se calmera
permettez moi de douter qu'ils aient
disparu depuis longtemps